qu'est ce qui vous attire le plus dans
nos régions
ce qui m'intéresse le plus qui m'attire
dans vos régions se sait le pays par
lui-même j'entends la topographie du
pays également l'habitat que je trouve
très jolie
parce que vous êtes satisfait des
terrains de camping de notre région
j'en connais deux pour l'instant celui
de wissembourg qui est en cours
d'aménagement
mais très bien situé près d'une rivière
celui de strasbourg mon dieu celui ci où
nous sommes présentement beaucoup moins
vous venez d charente maritime
aujourd hui des environs de la rochelle
qu'est ce qui vous a incité à venir en
alsace
eh bien je veux retourner dans le pays
où j'étais prisonnier pendant cinq ans
et comment trouvez-vous ce terrain de
camping le terrain continue bien j'ai
bien il est un peu petit mais bien
aménagé vous venez d codina qu'est ce
qui vous a incité à venir ici en alsace
pour camper là c'est à dire qu'on passe
simplement en alsace nous venons
d'allemagne c'est la première fois que
la première fois oui qu'est ce qui vous
plaît le plus moi je veux dire tout ce
qu'on a vu qu'on est le terrain de
camping comment le trouvez-vous
par comparaison à d'autres puisque vous
dire convergent pour nous je vais vous
dire franchement c'est finalement une
envie des conflits formidable
vous êtes anglais mme que je crois oui
madame
comment trouvez vous vous qui avez
l'habitude de compliquer travées citant
deux pays comment trouvez-vous nos
campings alsacien est ce qu'ils sont
bons propres oui j'aime beaucoup le
camping se trouve cette quinzaine mais
c'est très bon